All of us students here at Hillsdale, study
Pericles' Funeral Oration.
Thucydides records his words to the Athenians,
"The bravest are surely those who have the
clearest vision of what is before them, glory
and danger alike and yet not withstanding
go out to meet it."
A year ago American Conservatives were in
retreat and disarray.
The media chanted to Republicans, "You must
become moderates or go extinct.
The spectra of our new president's post Christian,
post American role loomed in progressive dominated
congress, courts and white house.
It seemed like there was no line left for
us to hold.
A few leaders saw the personal and political
dangers of standing fast by principle yet
forged on with vision.
As president of the Hillsdale College Republicans,
it's my honor to introduce you to one of those
leaders, congressman, Mike Pence of Indiana.
His uncompromising vision was recognized by
The American Conservative Union who honored
him in 2006 with The Courage Under Fire Award.
He was named Man of The Year in 2005 by Human
Events, standing among previous recipients
of this honors such as Justice Clarence Thomas,
Charlton Heston and Ronald Reagan.
He demonstrated his conviction by standing
against his own party opposing the Prescription
Drug Benefits Expansion of Healthcare Entitlements.
He voted against No Child Left Behind because
he believed it undermined local control of
education through it Federal mandates.
Something we at Hillsdale ought to know something
about.
He led the largest caucus in Congress, The
House Republican Study Committee which under
his chairmanship grew to 110 members and has
consistently given birth to intelligent conservative
alternatives to the behemoth state.
Last week on September 12th he told thousands
of Americans standing before the United States
Capital, "There's nothing that ails this government
that cannot be solved by paying more careful
attention to the principles enshrined in the
constitution of United States."
Like the beacon of truth, we shine here at
Hillsdale and now in Washington at the Kirby
Center, Congressman Pence continues in the
practices of the constitution and in the principles
of the Declaration of Independence that our
education has instilled in us.
On behalf of the Hillsdale College Republicans
and Hillsdale College, we are honored to present,
please welcome the Honorable Congressman,
Mike pence.
Mike Pence:
President and Mrs. Arnn, Mr. John Cervini.
Dr. David Bob and Elliot.
College Republicans and each and every one
of the faculty gathered here today and all
the students here at Hillsdale College who
have taken time, good evening.
As I'm sure you know, honor is what allows
us to do what is right despite the cost.
Even greater honor is required to do what
is right in the face of superior power and
the greatest honor is to stand strong even
when it means standing alone.
The long fight at Hillsdale College, standing
alone, then and now for the proposition that
all men are created equal, then with Fredrick
Douglas, now with Clarence Thomas.
Then and now in the conviction that Americans
are not horses, we were not born to have saddles
on our backs, by anyone, at any time, for
any reason.
This long fight you at Hillsdale have fought.
For love of ideas that did not come in dreams
or as Reagan said, "Did not spring full bloom
from your brow, but came from the heart of
a great nation."
Ideas that rose in a time of unprecedented
stress and genius and since the founding have
kept this country whole, prosperous, safe,
just and free.
It's therefore a profound honor for me to
stand before you in this place, so closely
associated with the founding of the Republican
Party, in our position to the unforgivable
sin of slavery, this place where statesmanship
is taught as an art and where right conduct
is seen its own reward.
I thank you and may God bless you and God
bless Hillsdale College.
I rise to pay a debt of honor and a debt to
history.
My subject today is the presidency.
My hope is that you will see that institution
in a new light and that you never despair
of the republic.
The presidency is the most visible thread
that runs through the tapestry of the American
government.
More often than not for good or for ill.
It sets the tone for the other branches and
spurs the expectations of the people.
It's powers are vast and consequential.
It's requirements from the outset and by definition,
impossible for mortals to fulfill without
humility and insistent attention to its purpose
as set forth in the constitution of the United
States.
Isn't it amazing given the great and momentous
nature of the office that those who seek it
seldom pause to consider what they're seeking?
Rather unconstrained by principle or reflection,
there seems to be a mad rush towards something
that once it's powers are seized, the new
president can wield it as an instrument with
which to transform the nation and the people
according to his highest aspirations.
Other than in the crisis of a house divided,
the presidency is neither fit nor intended
to be such an instrument.
When it is made that, the country sustains
a wound and cries out justly and indignity.
What the nation says, in the theme of this
address, what it says informed by its long
history, impelled by the laws of nature and
nature's God, what it says quite naturally
and rightly if not always gracefully is that
we as a people are not to be ruled and not
to be commanded.
It states that the president should never
forget this, that he has not risen above us
but is merely one of us, chosen by ballot,
dismissed after his term, tasked not to transform
and work his will upon us but to bare the
weight of decision and to carry out faithfully
the design laid in the constitution and impassioned
by the Declaration of Independence.
The presidency must adhere to its definition
as expressed in the constitution and to conduct
itself, the conduct that is defined over time
and tradition.
While the powers of the office have in large
with those of the Legislature and the Judiciary,
the framework of the government was actually
intended to restrict abuses common to classical
empires and the regal states of the 18th century.
Without proper adherence to the role contemplated
in the constitution for the presidency, the
checks and balances of the constitutional
plan become weakened.
This has been most obvious in recent years
when the three branches of government have
been subject to the tutelage of a single party.
Under either party, presidents have often
forgotten that they're intended to restrain
congress at times and that the congress is
independent of their desires.
That's fused in some unity, the political
class has raged forward in expansion of powers
and prerogatives, mistakenly assuming that
to exercise power is by default to do good.
Even the simplest among us knows that this
is not so.
Power is an instrument of fatal consequence.
It is confined no more readily than quick
silver and escapes good intentions as easily
as air flows through mesh.
Therefore, those who are entrusted with it
must educate themselves in self-restraint.
A republic, if you can keep it is about limitation
and for good reason, because we're mortal
and our actions are imperfect.
The tragedy of presidential decision is that
even with the best choice, some perhaps many
will be left behind and some, perhaps many
could die, because of this truth, the true
statesman lives continuously with what Churchill
called stress of soul, "He may give to Paul
but only because he robs Peter."
That is why you must be always weary of a
president who seems to float on his own greatness.
For all greatness is tempered by mortality,
every soul is equal.
Distinctions among men cannot be owned, they're
on loan from God who takes them back and evens
the accounts in the end.
It's a tragedy indeed the new generations
taking off as attribute failures in governance
to insufficient power and seek more of it.
In the Judiciary this is seldom been better
expressed than by Justice Thurgood Marshal
dictum that, "You do what you think is right
and let the law catch up."
In the congress it presents itself in massive
legislation, acts and codes, thousands of
pages long and so monstrously overcomplicated
that no human being can read through them
in a lifetime, much less understand them,
much less apply them justly to the people
that increasingly feel that they're no longer
being asked, they're being told.
Our nation finds itself in the position of
a dog, whose duty is not to ask why because
the why is too elevated for its nature, it's
simply to obey.
America is not a dog and does not require
a "Because I said so," jurisprudence to which
it's then commanded to catch up or legislators
who knit laws of such insulting complexity
that they're heavier than chains or a president
who acts like, speaks like and is received
as a king.
The presidency has run off the rails, it begs
a new clarity, a new discipline, a new president.
The president is not our teacher, our tutor,
our guide or ruler.
He does not command us, we command him.
We serve neither him nor his vision.
It is not his job or his prerogative to redefine
custom, law and beliefs, to appropriate industries,
to seize the country as it were by the shoulders
so as to impose by force theatrical charisma
his justice on 300 million others.
It is neither his job nor his prerogative
to shift the power of decision away from the
people to the accolades of his choosing.
Is my characterization of unprecedented presumptions
incorrect?
I defer to the judgement of the people which
they will make with their own eyes and ears.
Listen to the exact words of the leader of
the president's transition team and perhaps
his next chief of staff, who said two years
age, "It's important that president elect
Obama is prepared to really take power and
begin to rule day one."
More recently from the words of the latest
presidential appointment to avoid confirmation
by the senate, the new head of the Financial
Consumer Bureau wrote last Friday, "President
Obama understands the importance of leveling
the playing field and creating protections
that work not just for the wealthy or connected."
Take power, rule, leveling.
Though it is now, this has never been and
should never again be the model of the presidency
or the character of an American president.
No one can say this too strongly and no one
can say it enough until it is remedied, we
are not subjects we are citizens.
We fought our wars so that we don't even have
to treat kings like kings.
If I may remind you, we won that war.
Since then the principle of royalty has in
this country been inoperative and who is better
suited or more required to exemplify this
conviction in word and deed than the president
of the United states.
The powers of the presidency are extraordinary
and necessarily great and great presidents
treat them sparingly.
For example, it is not the president's job
to manipulate the nation's youth for the sake
of his agenda or his party's.
They're a portent political force when amassed
by the social network to which you're incessantly
connected.
If the president has their true interest at
heart, he will neither flatter them nor let
them adore him.
For in flattery is condensation and in adoration
is direction.
It's hard to say in this room but youth is
neither seasoned nor tested enough to direct
a nation, nor should it, the president's business
be to presume to direct them.
It's difficult enough to do right by your
own kids.
No one can be the father of all the nation's
youth.
Is the president therefore expected to turn
away from this and other easy advantage?
Yes.
Like Harry Truman who went to bed before the
result on election night, he must know when
to withdraw, to hold back, to forego attention,
publicity and advantage.
No finer or more moving or more profound understanding
of the nature of the presidency and the command
of humility placed upon it has ever been expressed
than by president Coolidge.
He like Lincoln lost a child while he was
president.
A son of 16.
Coolidge wrote, "The day I became president,
my son had just started working in a tobacco
field when one of his fellow laborer said
to him, if my father was president, I would
not be working in a tobacco field and young
Mr. Coolidge replied, if my father were you
father, you would."
His admiration for the boy was obvious.
While in the White House president Coolidge's
boy contracted blood poisoning from an incident
on the south lawn of the White House.
Coolidge wrote this words that a father can
understand, "What might have happened to him
under other circumstances we do not know but
if I'd not been president ..." Then he continues
"In his suffering he was asking me to make
him well and I could not."
When he went, the power and the glory of the
presidency went with him.
Sensibility such as this and not power is
the source of presidential dignity and must
be restored.
It depends entirely upon character, self-discipline
and an understanding of the fundamental principles
that underline not only the republic but life
itself.
It communicates that the president feels the
gravity of his office and is willing to sacrifice
himself.
His eye is not upon his own prospects but
on the storm of history through which it is
his responsibility to navigate with the specific
powers accorded to him and limitations placed
upon them not merely by man in his desire
but by God in His.
The modern presidency has drifted far from
the great strength and illumination of its
source.
The constitution has given life by the passionate
Declaration of Independence.
The Constitution terse, sober and specific
does not accept by implication address the
president's demeanor but this we can read
in the best qualities of the founding generation
which we would do well to imitate.
In the Capitol rotunda our heroic paintings,
one of the signing of the Declaration of Independence,
another of the victory at Saratoga another
of the victory at York Town.
Something seldom seen in history, there is
a painting of a general, the leader of an
armed rebellion resigning his commission and
turning his army over to a democratically
elected government.
Upon hearing from Benjamin West that George
Washington having won then war and then urged
to use the army to make himself king would
instead return to his farm, George III said,
"If he does that, he will be the greatest
man in the world."
He did and he was.
To aspire to such virtue and self-restraint
would be in a sense be difficult but in another
sense, it should be easy.
Difficult because it would be demanding and
ideal and easy because it is the right thing
to do and the rewards are immediate and self-evident.
A president who slights the constitution is
like a rider who hates his horse, he will
be thrown
and the nation along with him.
The president solemnly swears to preserve,
protect and defend the constitution.
He does not solemnly swear to ignore, overlook,
supplement or re-interpret it other than in
a crisis of morality, decency or existence
like the civil war.
If the president should want to hurry along
the constitution to fit his own notions or
designs he should do so by amendment rather
than adjustment, for if he joins the powers
of his office to his own willful interpretation
he steps away from a government of laws and
toward a government of men.
Is the constitution a fluctuating and inconstant
document?
A collection of suggestions, the purpose of
which is to stimulate debate in a future to
which the founders were necessarily blind?
Progressives tell us that even the framers
themselves could not reach agreement in its
regard but they did.
They did agree upon it and they wrote it down
and they signed it and they lived by it.
It's words are unchanging and unchangeable
except as planned by careful amendment.
There's no instruction to the president to
override the law and like Justice Marshal,
to let it catch up to his superior conception.
Why is this good?
It's good because the sun will burn out, the
Ohio river will follow backwards and a cow
will jump over the moon 10,000 times before
any modern president's conception is superior
to that of the founders of this nation.
Would it be such a great surprise that a good
part of the political strife of our times
is because one president after another rather
than keeping faith to it argues with the document
he is supposed to live by?
This discontent will only be calmed by returning
the presidency to the great first principles.
The president should regard the constitution
and the Declaration like an obsessed lover.
They should be on his mind all the time.
The prism through which the light of all questions
of governance passes, that we have sometimes
gradually, sometimes radically moved away
from this, we can move back to it.
Who better than the president to restore this
wholesome devotion.
As the president returns to the consistent
application of the principles of the constitution,
he will also by doing so ensure fiscal responsibility
and prosperity.
Who is better suited with his executive and
veto powers to carry over the duty of self-restraint
to the idea of fiscal solvency than the president
of the United States?
When the president restraints government spending,
leaving room for the American people to enjoy
the fruits of their labor, growth is inevitable.
As Senator Robert Taft wrote, "Liberty has
been the key to our progress in the past and
is the key to our progress in the future.
If we can preserve liberty in all its essentials
there is no limit to the future of the American
people."
Now, whereas at home the president must be
cautious, dutiful, differential, abroad his
character must change.
Were he to ask for a perimeter on how to act
in relation to other states which no holder
of the office has needed to this point.
Were that perimeter be written by the American
people in either 1776 or 2010, you can be
confident it will contain the following instructions.
You do not bow to kings.
The president of the United States of America
bows to no man.
When in foreign lands you do not criticize
your own country.
You do not argue the case against the United
States but rather the case for it.
You do not apologize to the enemies of the
United States of America.
Should you be confused, a country, a people,
a region that harbors, shelters, supports
or cheers attacks upon our country are enemies
of the United States
and to repeat, you do not apologize to them.
Closely related to this and perhaps the least
ambiguous of the president's complex responsibility
is his duty as commander in chief of our military.
In this regard there is a very simple rule,
unknown to some presidents regardless of party.
If ... It's perhaps the biggest if any president
can face.
Follow not just him but hundreds of thousands
or millions of others, not just for the rest
of their lives but in cost of blood and souls
be on life itself.
If ... It's an if that requires long and deep
hard thought, tremendously hard labor at determining
the truth of things, a lifetime of education,
a mind of a general, a wisdom of a statesman,
a heart of infantryman.
If after careful determination, intense stress
of soul and a deepest prayer, if then you
go to war and having gone to war by God, you
go to war to win.
You do not cast away American lives or those
of the innocent non-combatant enemy upon a
theory of gambit or a notion.
If the politics of your own election or your
party intrude on your decision for even an
instant, there're no words for this.
More common place but hardly less important
are other expectations of the president in
this regard.
He must not stint on the equipment and the
provisioning of our armed forces.
If he airs, it must not be on the side of
scarcity but on the side of surplus.
He must be the guardian of his troops, taking
every step to avoid even the loss of a single
American life.
The American soldier is as precious as the
closest of your kin because he is your kin
and for his sake the president must in effect
say to the Congress and to the people, "I'm
commander in chief, it is my sacred duty to
defend the United States and so I demand that
you give our soldiers everything they need
to complete the mission and come home safe."
Of all the hardest choices that Congress may
have to make to achieve that end, which one
of these things alone or in combination is
more terrible than the sacrifice of our children
or the defeat of our nation?
If in fulfilling this duty the president waivers
he will have betrayed his office.
This is not a policy it is probity
and it is not expedient artifact in my imagination.
It is written on the blood-soaked ground of
Saratoga, York Town, Antietam, Cold Harbor,
Guadalcanal, the Pointe du Hoc, the Chosin
Reservoir, Iraq and Afghanistan and a thousand
other places in our history, in lessons repeated
over and over again.
The presidency, a great and complex subject
upon which I've only touched has become symbolic
of overreaching.
There're many truths that we've been frightened
to tell or face.
If we run from them, they will catch us with
our backs turned and pull us down, better
that we should not flee but rather stop and
look them in the eye.
What might out forbearers say to us knowing
what they knew?
Having done what they did?
I have no doubt, they would tell us to channel
our passions, speak the truth and do what's
right, slowly and with resolution.
To walk calmly, steadily and without enemies
or fear.
To be like a rock in the tide, let the water
tumble about us and be firm and unashamed
in our love of country and so we are.
I see us like those in Philadelphia in 1776,
danger all around but a fresh chapter, ready
to begin, uncorrupted, with great possibilities
and inexplicably perhaps miraculously the
way clearing ahead.
I have never doubted that providence can appear
in history like the sun emerging from behind
the clouds if only as a reward for adherence
to first principles.
As Churchill said, "He must indeed have a
blind soul who cannot see that some great
purpose and design is being worked out here
below of which we have the honor to be faithful
servants."
A long time ago, during the tortured history
of Rome in the 4th century AD, the Emperor
Constantius, son of the Emperor Constantine
was faced by an ultimatum backed by what appeared
to be a military force impossible to resist.
Failure and defeat seemed certain but in the
morning when his answer was due, he said to
his assembled troops, "Last night, after I
retired to rest a shade of the great Constantine
rose before my eyes and his well-known voice
forbid me to despair of the republic."
We too have the voices of shades who emerge
from the past.
We too have what Lincoln in his first inaugural
called the mystic codes of memory stretching
from every patriot grave that bind us to the
greats and the humble, the known and the unknown.
If I hear them clearly, what they say is although
we may have strayed, we have not strayed too
far to return.
For we are everyone of us their descendants,
the seniors are still there lively waiting
to flex.
We can still astound the world with justice,
reason and strength.
I know this is true but even if it were not
we could not in decency stand down if only
for our death to history.
The death we owe to those who came before,
who did great things, who suffered more that
we suffer, who gave more than we give and
pledged their lives, their fortunes and their
sacred honor for us who they did not know
or as the old book says, "We drink from wells
we did not dig and are warmed by fires we
did not build."
We must remember and pay our debt to history.
Many generations are gone but I see them in
my mind's eye and by the character and memory
of their existence, they forbid us to despair
of the republic.
I see them crossing the prairies in the sun
and wind and see their faces looking out from
steel mills and coal mines and immigrant ships
crawling into the harbors at dawn.
I see them at war, at work and at peace.
I see them long departed, looking into the
camera with hopeful and sad eyes.
I see them embracing their children who became
us.
They are our family and our blood we cannot
desert them, in spirit all of them come down
to all of us in a connection that out of love,
we cannot betray.
They're silent now and forever but from the
eternal silence of every patriot grave there's
yet an echo that says, "It's not too late,
keep faith with us, keep faith with God and
do not, do not ever despair of the republic."
Thank you and God bless you.